okay so i will talk about uh witness
encryption this is a primitive that was
suggested about a decade ago and
essentially it is an encryption scheme
or you can take an instance of some
computationally hard problem and say
that you encrypt the message with
respect to it in such a way that only if
someone has a witness that solves this
problem then they can decrypt and
otherwise if there is no uh witness then
it is impossible to decrypt
so it is useful in cases where for
example the encryptor himself does not
know if some computational problem is
is feasible or not so they can say i
have this prize for someone that might
in the future be able to solve it and
then i encrypt uh the message with
respect to the problem and if in a few
decades from now someone will manage to
compute the solution then they can use
their witness and automatically they
will be able to decrypt
so
a syntax of such scheme is relatively
simple the only thing we have is an
encryption algorithm so the encryption
algorithm uh and of course a decryption
algorithm
so the encryption
takes the message that should be
encrypted and in addition a verification
algorithm that takes a witness and then
either accepts or rejects it
and the decryption should work only if
someone uh presents a valid witness for
this verification algorithm and
otherwise if there is
if there does not exist a valid witness
then the decryption should be hard for
everyone so there are no additional
decryption keys and there is no
interactive security game or anything of
this sort
yeah so
since the introduction of this model
there have been a few attempts to come
up uh with candidates
so there is one candidate with probable
security for multi-linear maps
and a few years after that a few
additional candidates were suggested
from lattice-based assumptions but we do
not know how to analyze their security
so they are there we believe that they
are secure but we do not know how how to
prove that
and of course with the recent uh
advances uh from uh of uh in this movie
of io uh we can use io to also uh derive
witness encryption but then we need to
go through a really long line of
reductions and we lose the intuition
about the security somewhere along the
way so
uh it is still interesting to try and
come up with a scheme that is
simple in some sense so we can
better understand why it is secure and
even if we don't know how to prove it we
can still point out uh the the missing
uh piece in the puzzle and say this is
the the only thing that we need to prove
in order uh to to show that this is
secure
so this is this was our motivation
and
we we suggest uh a construction uh from
lattice assumptions and we also
can analyze its security and we can
prove that it's secure under a new
assumption which turns out that is not
you because uh
at the same time a hote came up with a
very very similar
assumption that he just
discussed in the previous talk
and actually we see this uh as a
as an encouraging thing because it means
that first other people uh think that
this is something reasonable to assume
and try to think about it
and second of all it means that the
assumption is not too specific for our
construction and has other applications
like the broadcasting encryption that
the topic showed
okay
so the computation uh the computational
model that we will use is a branching
program
so in a bunch of program we have
evaluation steps that should be applied
sequentially
and we sometimes also call them levels
and in the first level
there is
there is a state that is defined to be
the start state and in the final level
there is a state that is defined to be
the accepting state and all of the other
ones are rejecting and then in each step
we have uh
two mappings uh one mapping for uh one
and one mapping for zero i denote them
here by
blue and orange
and in addition there is a definition
for each step of the evaluation
which
bit of out of the input bits should be
read so in each step where in order to
evaluate uh the the program in each step
we would have to look at one of the
input bits and depending on its value we
either apply
uh the zero
the zero um
uh mapping or the one mapping and move
to the next step
yeah so just as an example if uh we have
an input of length four and we need uh
to read to read its bits seven times
so
we can
each time
take one of the mappings according to
the bits and then we would end up with
some state and here we ended up with a
rejecting state so the output of the
program should be zero and if we were to
end up in the accepting state then the
output would be one
okay so according to uh barcode's
theorem in fact for every
function that can be computed in
polynomial time we can express it as a
branching program of polynomial size so
yeah you don't care about fixed widths
right uh you can you can
yeah as long as it is
the number of nodes is polynomial it's
fine but
see that the width is of fixed
is fixed to five and then
the length is polynomial
okay
so now
assume that we want to design a weakness
encryption uh based on a branching
program
so as i said earlier the only thing we
have to work with is the encryption
algorithm
and we need to somehow exploit uh the
structure of the branching program uh in
order to to have
this mechanism that you can only decrypt
if there is a valid witness
so we need to somehow make use of the
starting node and somehow make use of
the n node
and then because the encryptor itself
does not know uh what is going to be a
valid witness we also must uh provide
some flexibility for the decrypter to
choose how to evaluate uh the the
machine so we need
it needs to be possible to either take
the the zero mapping or the one mapping
for each and every step
so a reasonable and high level approach
would be to somehow define
a one part of the cipher text that is
associated with the starting node
another part of the ciphertext that is
associated with the node and then for
each
step to provide the two keys that allow
to either take
the zero mapping or the one mapping
um but recall that when we come to now
analyze the security of a candidate that
has this structure
then the only assumption that we have as
as the proverb of the security is that
there does not exist any valid witness
and we when we translate this assumption
to the structure of the punching program
it means that the only thing we have to
work with is
is the fact that there is no uh valid
path from the starting node uh to the
accepting note
and the problem with this assumption is
that it is not true
because the because we know that there
are no uh valid witnesses but there
might still be some paths from the start
node to the accepting node but it will
not uh satisfy uh the rules of which
bit should be read at each step
so for example here we have an input
sequence that violates uh the rule of
which bits should be used because uh the
first and the last bits uh should be
identical
but uh it still results in a path uh
that is accepting as and
if we give the crypto the flexibility to
the flexibility to
uh
to
to take uh the mapping that he wants in
each step
then he can use this kind of
attack to eventually decrease
and just uh as a side note actually in
branching programs that do not
have this kind of
reading
the same bits multiple times it's
actually trivial uh to get a witness
encryption because
the encryptor himself can check
can apply uh bfs or dfs from the
starting node and
if if there exists any path from the
starting of the accepting node we can
translate it to a valid witness and then
it becomes a trivial to encrypt so
this is the challenge and this is uh the
only interesting challenge that should
be faced
so you're saying satisfiability is
trivial then so is witness encryption
satisfiability for emphasis trivial yeah
you can check the satisfiability and if
there is a witness you you put the
message into clear and otherwise you you
output
yeah okay
so to overcome that uh our starting
point is uh a generalization of a
branching program that was uh suggested
by chen ethan and it allows to detect
when the program is evaluated with
inconsistent sequences
so
the generalized model considers a
branching problem that instead of
holding
a single state in each uh step it starts
with multiple steps
and then whenever uh we take an
evaluation step we we we need to update
all of these states uh simultaneously
either
according to the one nothing or to the
zero mapping
and then after uh
after we applied that so we will also
end up with multiple states so there
also
there also should be some rule that
defines uh takes as input the the vector
that represents uh
the the output the last level and then
either accept or reject it depending on
the active nodes
so given this generalization of a
bunching program we can now apply a
consistency checking in the following
manner
so the way i like to think about it is
that
for each bit of the input
we add additional component to the
branching program that takes care of
verifying that one of the input bits is
is
is applied consistently
so i will not go into all of the details
but it is relatively simple
but in high level we can for example
if you want to have a memory cell for
the second bit so we can add four
additional states one of them represents
that this bit was not ready yet another
one represents that it was red and it
was zero every time that it was read the
same for one and the let's say state uh
denotes that it was inconsistent and
then we can
define the the mapping rule such that
they always keep satisfying
those four states and eventually we say
that as long
as we didn't go to the inconsistent
state then we can accept and only if we
were inconsistent we
rejected so now given a standard
branching program we can concatenate to
it all of these memory cells one for
each input bit
and we end up with this
slightly larger a branching
program and
for each of the components we have the
whether it accepts or rejects and now we
need to have one final rule uh for this
concatenated program so we will simply
say that the large program accepts if
each of the each of the components
accepted the evaluation
so just as an example if we have a
valid a sequence
a sequence that is consistent uh with
some input then all of the memory cells
will accept
and if we have a bad input
then
the bit when we were inconsistent its
memory cell will detect that and reject
so now let's get into the lattice
techniques uh that we're going to use
for the construction
so we're going to use a variant of ggh15
encodings and this is essentially a way
to generate lattice problems according
to a structure of a directed graph
in very high level so suppose we have an
example a
directed graph we will associate with
each node
some public matrix
and for each edge
some lwe secret
and then there is an encoding algorithm
that works for an edge
so it takes this input a trapdoor of the
source matrix
and it takes the target matrix and in
addition it takes
the secret that is associated with this
edge and it outputs something that is
called an encoding for this edge
respective to the secret that we defined
for this edge
now the the
nice thing about these encodings is that
they have two properties
first they allow to convert an lwe
instance with respect to the source
matrix to an lw instance with respect to
the target matrix but the other property
is that they also
leave some place that remembers the edge
that we use
so for example here we have two possible
paths from a to b and depending on the
encoding that we chose to use we will
end up with different
secrets for the lwe instance with
respect to b
so this idea was applied on branching
programs for multiple use cases
in some of them we know how to prove
security and in some of them not so
uh it was mostly used for a variance of
candidates of
io but also for a constrained prf
so
how would this be applied on a branching
program
we will
associate
each node with the matrix so
there should be more air matrixes here i
just didn't want to overload the slide
but every node would have some metrics
associated with it and
we denote the starting matrix by a and
the accepting matrix by b
and then for each
for each evaluation step we also sample
two lwe secrets one for zero and one for
one and we associate each edge of each
level with uh the secret uh that
corresponds uh to its mapping
so
the answer quantum matrices
so this should be sampled with the
trapdoor so you can compute the
encodings
and
and in the last level the tbd
i mean
uh generally yeah like here is like a
general use case so b would typically be
uh random and all of the other matrixes
should be assembled with the strato
so now in order to to compute an an
encoding for a branching program we will
provide an lw instance with respect to
the starting matrix and then for each
edge we will compute an encoding like we
saw before
respective to the
to the secrets uh that are associated
with this edge
yeah so now let's say that we have uh
this encoding and we want to evaluate
the branching program
so
we start with the lrwe instance of the
starting node
and every time we want to apply one of
the mappings we use the appropriate
encoding
so the k that corresponds to the
to the bit of this uh step and it has
the property that if we multi multiply
them sequentially then the this trace of
the secrets
will add up and we will end up
at
the the final state of the program
so here i chose the path that goes to
the accepting state so we end up with an
nwe instance with respect to b and of
course i i assume that there are errol
teams here i just didn't try them uh but
then we also have this uh this memory
that remembers which path uh we showed
in order to get to the accepting state
and
it turns out that actually uh even
though uh this uh terms of this form are
highly structural they actually have
they have a lot of
computational entropy and they can even
be used as as a as a prf so
even though
we always use here the same b matrix the
fact that we have a different
multiplication for every
x is enough to state that terms of this
form look uh random of course if there
is an arrow here if we see them for
multiplexes
something so how are you checking for
inconsistency of input here what
happened are you checking for
inconsistency of inputs here
yes so i didn't get to that yet this is
just an example
this is actually the connecticut
period just an example on how to apply
and produce on the branching form
okay and also note that this is just
a standard voltage problem it doesn't
have the multiple
active states
right so now let's try to apply a
similar idea to a state that has
multiple active states simultaneously so
this is the branching program that
we saw earlier
uh
so now
for every starting node
we will
associate it with some metrics
and in the in the output layer uh we
sample matrices uh in the following way
so recall that
we said that the machine accepts uh the
output only if each of its components
ending in an accepting state so this can
be thought as an
end of all right for each uh component
we have an over condition and then
eventually we have in the end condition
of all of them so we can apply an
information theoretic secret sharing the
according to this formula
so for each component we sample a random
matrix and tie it to each node that is
accepting
and eventually for the
for the last node here it is first but
for one of the for one of the components
and when we define it's accepting uh
it's a certain state to be associated
with the sum of all of the other
matrices
okay
so now the encoding
will be an lwe instance with respect to
each of the static nodes and also
encoding for all of the edges like we
saw in the example earlier
so
what does this structure give us
so
intuitively
we can now start
from each of the starting nodes
according to our choice and we can also
choose any evaluation sequence that we
want and then we will end up in one of
the output states and if we end up in a
rejecting state so assume that this is
just a random metric so this is not
interesting and if we end up in an
accepting state so we will get a term
that that has the matrix b of the
accepting state with the trace that
remembers the the
the paths that we chose to evaluate
so if this is if you set b sub f to be
the what you what you wrote class b
so there is no
b you
uh
here that is a b because i i meant like
either of those days
uh sorry say again
you say again so
matrix right you could this would be a
constraint bri
right uh so so if everything checked out
you would get the product of s's
indexed by x times b that's the output
of the pr right otherwise
something went wrong uh you know either
you were not consistent or you were in a
reject state
but but then where would they put that
be in terms of associating it with uh
minus the sum of b sub j
right now your b is zero
that's right yeah that's right
exactly thank you yeah so it depends on
on the application
exactly
okay
so
uh
yeah so i didn't say but the encryption
would be
the witness encryption would be to
either provide a
this circle or to give a uniformly
random vector
depending on the base that we want to
entry
so
before i go into the
security analysis which is the longer
part let's
see them
let's see their correctness
so
uh
suppose that i have a valid weakness so
i can use the mapping that determines
the evaluation sequence that corresponds
to it
and then i can evaluate the machine and
uh because it is consistent then each of
the memory cells will end up in an
accepting state and also the component
that evaluates f will end up in the
accepting states and then i get
an lwe instance both with respect to b
and with respect to each of these
matrices and because when they are
summed up we end up
with zero we can sum up all of these
terms
and then depending on whether this was
an actual lw instance or not we will
either get something uniform or or
something small
and we can learn uh what was the
encrypted bit
okay
so
uh for the security so
before we go into the structure of the
proof let's analyze all of the possible
cases
so
let's think about an evaluation sequence
uh that is a consistent it does not
violate the consistent the consistency
checks it is consistent with some
weakness
so
we know by the assumption of the
security that there shouldn't be a
witness that is accepted by by the
machine so
it must be the case that
that the the first component that
actually computes f will end up in a
rejecting state so even if all of these
all of the cells are accepting here we
will end up in the injecting state and
we will not be able to to derive an lw
instance with respect to bf that also
has a trace of this uh sequence x
so this is in case well we were
honest and using a consistent transcript
now let's assume that we're trying to
track the machine and use a sequence
that violates the consistency
so there must be at least one index j
where it is inconsistent
and therefore its memory cell will end
up in the rejecting
and we will not be able to compute an
lwe instance according to the matrix of
this memory cell also with the trace
of this translate x
so in either case no matter which
transcript we use
we can never manage to get lwe instances
with respect to all of the matrix matrix
matrices that all have the same
trace of evaluation sequence
okay so yeah before i go into the
analysis i just want to say
why intuitively this should be secure
because we saw earlier that uh this
structure of s values uh adds a lot of
uh sunday randomness and in fact even
when even if all of the b matrices were
identical if we could only see one
instance of them then
these these values
would look uniformly random so
even though we see here uh
multiple
values
uh
according to to the same transcript as
long as they looking from the random
this uh should look uh
this should be fine
the gth15 keys right that are the what
you put in the arrows the recording keys
they are correlate so rather
you said a to b right now you're doing
many a's to many beats and those b's are
actually correlated right this b1 b1 b1
that's why you cannot full security
using the standard technique
right right yeah
and that would be true even if you
replace the b sub f by the one that we
were discussing you know b a random
matrix b minus
[Music]
so as long as all of the matrices of the
next level are somewhat correlated you
cannot apply the standard analysis
but the intuition says that because for
each secret we can only see a subset of
the matrices and those are not
correlated then hopefully uh we can
believe that this is uh
okay so now let's see how how to um
how to analyze this
so let's go back to the toy example we
started with the gh encoding so
typically
the analysis would take the following
steps so
if b is a random matrix we know that lwe
with respect to it is half
and then
it is
not trivial but uh
it was shown that we can simulate uh the
encodings instead of using the trapdoor
of a
and because we no longer need a trapdoor
pha we can sample a uniformly random
instead of generating it with the
tableau and then
now we can say that also lw with respect
to a is hard and
if a had more predecessor then we could
apply this argument again and again
depending on the structure of the graph
so
in the standard branching
program
we can apply a similar argument as long
as all of the matrices here are random
so
we can we can say that lw with respect
to b is hard because it is generated
without the throttle and the uniformly
random
and then because of that we can simulate
the
the encodings that were used to to
to point to it
and and now we no longer need the
trapdoors of the previous level so we
can also generate it
uniformly at random
and then we can apply it again and again
and again so we analyze the machine from
and to start
and then we will end up uh
with the start level that is also
uniformly random and we can say that lwe
with respect to a is now hard because a
is without the toggle so this is the
standard analysis
methodology
but now let's go back to the
construction we cannot apply it here
because
the matrices here are correlated so we
cannot state that lwa with respect the
matrixes the matrices here is hard
because it is not
uh but we still have uh the intuition
that we had earlier that's in fact the
attacker can never see an lwe instance
with respect to all of these matrices
simultaneously this is uh these are the
cases that we went over earlier
so
let's take this intuition and
and uh define
and experiment according to it this
would be our first step in the analysis
so we defined a special lwe experiment
we have an oracle that has all of the
values related to the system how
according to it so it has
the initial secret and then also each
secret that is associated to each level
of the program and also has all of the
output matrixes
and then we have an adversary and the
adversary
can send a transcript
of his choice and he will receive back
an lwe instance uh which the trace
the secret race that corresponds to this
transcript and then only a output b
matrices that can be
accessed according to the branching
program so
if this transcript is is consistent for
the j bit he will receive
the l w with respect to b j
and if this transcript
leads to the accepting state of the
component that computes a f then he will
receive lw with respect to bf and
assuming that there is no valid witness
like we saw earlier
uh it means that he can never receive a
an lwe instance
for matrices that are
correlated so this is an experiment that
knows the branching program right
the the oracle knows the branching
program yes because it needs to be able
to figure that yeah yeah
so this
this captures the intuition on why we
believe this should be secure right
so in a sense you're saying the only way
i can try to decrypt the witness
encryption is if i try a witness one at
a
time a translated one at the time yeah
yeah
okay so
so in fact if we assume that this is the
security game we can prove from standard
lwa that
that this experiment is hard
exactly yeah that the adversary cannot
tell whether he receives a uniform
responses over
or from this distribution
and
so we can prove that this that this
experiment is hard
but
the proof
requires a unique hybrid for every
evaluation sequence we we handle them
one by one depending on whether
they
they are consistent or inconsistent and
then we end up with with exponential
number of hybrids
but i just want to point out that uh the
original walks uh that most of the one
that
suggested the notion of weakness
encryption and the one that suggested
that construction for multi-linear maps
uh so in their construction they also
require exponential number of hybrids
and they gave some
reasoning on why it should be the case
and the listening is something along the
lines of if we had an efficient proof
then we could use this proof to decide
the language more or less
it has it has some asterisks but but
it is uh
it doesn't match uh the same challenges
that they had in the proof
but in this experiment anniversary
submit inquiry so it's more like a prf
experiment instead of not knowing where
to see experiment
as opposed to what
it's like
it is
the heuristic in some sense
implicit here is that the only way i can
try to use the witness encryption is by
evaluating it on a polynomial number of
points
the reduction still need to run
exponential time if you are in more sort
of the prf experiment
depends on the function
and if you could find an input on which
it outputs uh
one on which it accepts then you could
easily distinguish so somehow to be able
to argue that you can't distinguish you
kind of have to know that there's no uh
there's no input on which
point is that uh you're only getting
these uh these these answers in response
to particular axis and i can only quite
vulnerably many x's so why do you need
uh
exponential
right yeah
if the adversary was sending the
instance the witness encryption instance
then it's a different story right but uh
yeah the person did not see the witness
encryption instance this is the output
for any particular act that you can
obtain
and this is only you can only ask for
putting on a number of them
yeah so we define this experiment and
then we can
show that this experiment
is hard in the case where there is no
valid witness
but now we also need to somehow claim
that the original security game
of the
against the actual intention is
equivalently called as this
ideal experiment
so yeah this is why we did an assumption
uh so we went with the
subscription security game is uh
or at least almost as hard
as as the experiment which is defined
and this is uh while we
show the new assumption which is
extremely similar to patrick's invasive
lw assumption which essentially says
that the only thing that they adversary
can do with with his encodings is to
evaluate the branching problem
from from start to end and the fact that
he has these encodings that does not
give him any extra leverage beyond using
them as they are supposed to do so
this also can be thought of as the semi
honest security of the
of the dragon
so the way
we find it that
again this is a simplified
version what appeals in the battle but
suppose that we have a matrix a and a
matrix b and a typical sample from a to
b
then the game where we have uh
nwa with respect to the matrix a and we
get this accelerator information
disruptor sample
is at least as hard as an lwe experiment
uh with respect to the matrix a and b
and well we don't get the trouble sample
so
in context assumption he said that
if this game is hard then this game is
hull
and and here i need something slightly
stronger which is that
this is at least as hard as this i i
don't know yet whether this is hard so i
cannot assume in my proof that this is
hard and then use it in order to claim
that this is hard
the only thing i can claim is that
this experiment is as hard as this
experiment
what does as hard as me
what is what was it as hard as me
so
the way it is formally defined is that
for every adversary with uh some
advantage
uh in this game we have an adversary uh
with some advantage in this game with
similar advantages in this game plus
something as well so you're also looking
at the indistinguishability to see the
render
yeah
exactly so it's the other way around
right unless i'm missing something if
there's an absolute that breaks the left
guy
then there's an adversary
i mean the other direction is is uh is
trivial right because if someone breaks
that one and then we get uh
this kind of challenge we can apply the
structure
uh so then we apply this assumption from
the beginning of the pointy program
towards the end of it and
recall that
the real cipher text includes
edibly centered with respect to the
starting nodes and then all of these
encodings and then
in each step we apply this assumption
and we replace the encodings of one of
the evaluation steps with the matrices
that the other side could access if you
want to use them on
all of the lobby it's success that he
currently has
so we apply this for each step and then
eventually we end up in the game where
the adversary has no encodings at all
but now we can access uh exactly all of
the states that he could access as we
defined in the in the experiment on the
previous side so so so you know this is
a formal statement here is that for
every adversary that breaks one there is
an adversary potentially with a larger
run time that breaks the other
polynomial
so so if you sort of repeat you're
probably going to repeat it for every uh
step of the branching program right
so now the runtime
of the adversary potentially blows up
right
at the end
yeah but i'm i i do not apply it
for every uh
starting matrix and edge i apply it uh
just for every encoding
so it is you can hack it depending on
how you define
the assumption right
um
even for every encoding you have many
layers
so it depends on how you do the hybrids
did you solder seven is the one hybrid
per layer
yeah
i i mean i guess what we're asking is
that if he can if he already has access
to many mattresses and now we apply the
assumption for each met if each source
matrix and each edge then it works
exponentially that's what you mean yeah
so
the way i first assumption is that
because i assume that even if he has
this oracle access to many mattresses he
runs in polynomial time so and because
this is an experiment i guess an
overhead and we can
only apply the trapdoor polynomial times
in each step
so
so
the way that the assumption is phrased
is is again as an interactive game
against an adversary because i never
want to assume that he has a
as actual input of the lw instance since
here it is always
formalized as a game against this
overhead
and then i assume that the cost of
applying and encoding is similar to one
evaluation step so
so this translates
to one query to the outcome
so the proof course
applies this assumption
then
it applies the assumption related the
theoretical assumption yeah alternately
is that is that
so here so this is the
the overview of the proof so we start
with the real encryption and then
we first apply the assumption
for all of the steps
and in each step we
so
actually we have this model of lwe
oracle with respect to
to the specialized distribution like we
defined uh
in the experiment so we define
intermediate experiments for each level
uh
for each level of the bounty program
where we can only access lwe samples
according to the to the secrets and the
partials the function
so we first apply it from the beginning
to end
and only then we end up with the
experiment that i described earlier
and then we can start to tackle each
of each sequence individually
yeah so
that's the last slide so if you have
more questions now it's a good time
should you go back to slide but that's
not so big
are you using the assumption like small
matrices or these
like like how
the experiment you gave
the adversary sees
um
became very different
i guess i'm trying to match the querying
and the oracle aspect of the experiment
with the assumptions
and then each uh
each metric cell actually has some index
attached to it and uh adversary sends an
index and receives an elderly with
respect to the
matrix that corresponds to this index so
there's like an expansion of both a
matrices and b major
but i assume that he can only access the
polynomial number of them if you answer
polynomial time
this is equivalent like uh
him um computing the uh
partial path and then querying uh the
intermediate value that you would get
giving it
and you see
you have assumed these exponential
number of matrices can be like arbitrary
they don't have some system description
or something like that it can just be
arbitrary exponential ace arbitrary
exponential b's
i mean they do have a success
description because they depend only on
the mattresses of the
of the future
but in the assumption you say even if
so these exponential number of matrices
is what again like the partial subset
products the partial subset products of
s times uh b as well something like that
yeah but in the intermediate steps it
won't be b because it won't be the
output matrix it will be some
intermediate
matrix of the branching program so
we go back to like
a drawing of yeah so it will be like
up until to this point like uh
all of the
possible prefixes of uh
of the excess and these public methods
some questions